[Musique]
appelé si je travaille par le ministre via pouvez-
vous arrêter
[Applaudissements]
où je viens de tout le monde est le bienvenu
quelle que soit la nationalité et si
j'essayais le ministre c'est ce que je comprends
[Musique]
nous avons des nouvelles de dernière heure une grande
explosion s'est déclenchée  dans le centre de la ville,
nous suspendrons les activités jusqu'à ce que nous
obtenions plus d'informations d'
accord, je suis un muscle fede vous avez entendu parler de
la bombe dans la ville oui j'ai été envoyé
pour sécuriser l'île en
fait puis-je voir votre carte d'identité ouais bien sûr
[  Musique]
quelque chose a mal tourné et nous
devons savoir ce qui reste tout le long du chemin, nous
allons traverser cela Je veux vous faire
voir quel est le tunnel
Je veux juste le battre alors peut-être que c'est
votre chance
la personne qui a arrêté il a demandé  pour moi
pourquoi il y a des témoins dont j'ai besoin pour
contre-interroger la Norvège n'est pas en procès
vous êtes sûr de cela
je ne veux tout simplement pas que chaque semaine ne soit pas
devant lui
vous pouvez être faible et toujours fort vous
savez que c'est vrai je  ont encore des
arbres d'espoir
en France
et c'est  utilisé pour vous vivre